[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans encore vont
l'émission qui reçoit des personnages
que vous avez forcément déjà vu au ciné
ou à la télé avec aujourd'hui à l'invité
habitué à prendre la parole lors des
scènes de mariage ou de conférence de
presse mais toujours à sa manière je
reçois le personnage qui avait prévu un
discours sur des petites fiches est mais
qui finalement préfère improvisé
homme qui avait prévu un discours sur
des petites fiches est mais qui
préfèrent improvisé bonjour bonjour
alors est ce qu'après toutes ces années
vous arrivez encore à créer la surprise
oui les gens s'attendent toujours à ce
que je fasse un discours est d'ailleurs
pour vous expliquer j'ai préparé un
petit message à d'accord le sam est
robuste et pas prévu mais vous savez
dans la vie
je veux pas faire toi tu sais il m'a eu
c'est qu'il ya plein de manières de
surprendre là j'ai juste baisser le bras
mais il ya plein d'autres manières
d'accord vous avez d'abord le jeu taz
l'anaf outre désinvolture oui très très
prisé dans le film français le pliage
range âge très méticuleux et enfin on a
le déchirage lançage alors la dramatique
normatif mais lors tout est quand même
très maîtrisée j'ai l'impression vous
savez ce qu'est ce qu'il va pas
initialement avec ce discours qu'elle
commença mais pourquoi s'en débarrasser
comme ça au dernier moment they
schizophrène
donc c'est une fille finalement c'est
légal au moins ce que je fais mais
écologiquement parlant vous pensez à
l'impact de toutes ces feuilles comme ça
a lancé aval vau-l'eau si les papiers
recyclés vous devrez cycle et passent à
excuser moi je veux que vous me servez
encore et toujours la même recette vous
êtes sincères chez c'est vous essayé
mais vous n'y arrivez pas ces fiches
sont pour vous des cartes que vous
abattez vulgairement à la face du
téléspectateur pour créer un effet
scénaristique assez moyens partent on ne
va pas se mentir un os en fait je suis à
mon de la mariée en fait je suis iron
man la belle affaire qu'est ce qui nous
dit pas que sur vos fiches et écrit
lancer ses fiches à ce moment là est-ce
que vous pouvez au moins une fois dans
votre vie nous dire pourquoi vous lisez
pas ce discours ou alors lisez le bisou
allez-y non vous n'avez pas envie
arrêtez de dire vous n'avez pas envie
alors pourquoi vous n'avez pas envie de
lire dites nous pourquoi
pourquoi
pardon je sais pas lire
il ne sait pas lire et c'est ainsi que
se termine cet épisode encore vous pas
un scoop mais c'est moi vous présenter
mon prochaine invitée qui habille les et
c'est aussi bon excusez moi je été très
dure avec vous là je pars donc non je
peux pas le faire
pas mal hein ah ben ouais magnifique et
j'étais censé à hyper sincère d'accord
laissez moi vous dire bravo
qu'est ce qu'on fait non non arrêtez
arrêtez ça c'est pas vous non parce
qu'en effet juste après la pause nous
recevrons le personnage qui démarrent
les standing ovation en applaudissant
doucement puis de plus en plus vite
personne ne voulait le recevoir et
pourtant moi j'ai décidé de faire comme
ça que je fonctionne au coup de coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon allez je te laisse je vais faire un
autre cliché là je vais rejoindre ma
femme à l'aéroport pour l'empêcher de
prendre l'avion je vais faire le
meilleur mix ton corps elle souffre
j'ai laissé partir l'amour de ma vie
c'est pas la meilleure que moi
et n'oublie pas si les parties